bullshit hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic
I remember it so you don't have to it's
Halloween
time to look at another memorable movie
and go oh that day Nate well it's
Stephen King time
it's usual I have to start out praising
this guy before I piss on this guy
because the dude does have met Helen and
has written a lot of awesome stories but
however they don't translate well to
film or they just pick the worst ones to
adapt his movies and miniseries rarely
show the strength of his abilities often
resulting in hilarious results scaring a
little girl and to start off this review
how about a dramatic reenactment of how
king chooses what to write about next
children of the corn
based on Kings short story Childre the
corn looks at an already popular scary
subject creepy kids and for some reason
combines them with a yellow vegetable
that's about as scary as well
balloons does it pay off well if you
like to get paid in these it done tons
of sequels a cult status and of course
hundreds of people around the world
saying there's better King movies that
could be made than this let's see if
King can turn shock horror into shuck
horror
this is children of the corn the film
opens up three years ago with a
narration from a kid named Jobe I was
the only kid in church that day the
others one with Isaac at the cornfield I
didn't get to go cuz dad didn't like
Isaac he was pretty smart my dad why was
thought to my daily beating I was on
account of my bowtie and that I talk
like a complete tool but kids start to
surround a cafe led by their Amish mafia
leader Isaac and get ready to take it
down and with wallpaper like that do you
really blame them
oh come on this is just a Friday night
at Denny's after making a hand sandwich
Jill continues to narrate while
seemingly having no emotional reaction
talking about his father being killed
right in front of him it happened
everywhere and get one that day that's
when Sara started drawing these pictures
oh they also served me my father at the
international hell of pancakes but I
really want to talk about my sister's
drawings we then cut to three years
later we're just graduated doctor wakes
up in a hotel well gee with the lack of
detail they're showing in this scene I'm
just positive something terrible is
about to happen I help my fake out music
didn't wake you
this is bird played by Peter Horton and
Vicky played by Linda Hamilton and what
do you think one three I got a couple
things iterator two packs of cigarettes
a day live half
proposal no they're heading towards an
internship well mockingly making fun of
preachers on the radio I guess that's a
thing amen peanut butter okay
no room for people who watch Public
Television oh no commitment hey man come
on as someone who likes to make fun of
religious practice I hate that you won't
commit to that religious practice and of
course the internship is just near our
town of tiny pointless narrators we
weren't the only one to thought as a
career
I took slaughtering a village falls into
the rear category how about we weren't
the only ones who thought Isaac was a
buzzkill
and that he'd kill you with a buzz saw
if you didn't like the way you looked
one kid tries to escape the man has to
get help leaving his two friends behind
listen you tell anybody I'm gone
if you tell you're gonna burn on the
lake of fire for all eternity we won't
cross your heart hope to die stick a
needle in your eye why do you even have
that rhyme it sounds like the lake of
fire would be a million times worse
thanks for shouting my escape you little
dumbasses I'll be sure to let you keep
my head if they were moving from my body
no real surprise they do end up finding
him but not before like I said they try
to somehow make Koren actually scary
no he'll fill me with dietary fiber so
one of the kids finds him and kills him
gee I can't imagine how they were tipped
off to that but luckily our two main
characters are there to save the day
but I could have gone better hang on let
me check let me check yeah make sure
she's okay before you check on the kid
yes steamrolled with your car you're
gonna be a great doctor what wasn't
animal uh yeah an animal let's go he
goes to check on the kid noticing that
his throat has been slit so I want you
to go back to the car and wait for me
there understand and keep all the doors
locked until I get back
why where are you going tell you when I
get back just do what I say it is a
little weird telling Sarah Connor to
wait in the car I don't think your
sensitive mind can hear the truth yet
it's like telling the rock not to look
at a paper cutter he'll pass out it's
just weird but she eventually can't take
it and finds that she has to look at the
body herself I'm so sorry
Oh bird I had the worst jump-scare dream
it did tie into the story was completely
point it's okay we still killed a kid oh
thank god that calms me down so they put
the kid in the trunk and drive off
because that doesn't seem fucking
suspicious as I try to forget about
their kid killing by putting on the
radio that'll work
getting tired of that crap I mean how
many King films have religious bashing
now you can make fucking playing cards
out on it I really think we should over
they also decide to open up the kid's
briefcase because bad enough they killed
him they might as well Rob them to Jesus
Christ not my book it's like some sort
of primitive folk art I think it's
repulsive
he should see more tolerance from Bill
Maher on Islam do the church thing you
as a child or something they
surprisingly come across a mechanic who
seems to be the only adult left in town
which is kind of odd did they keep him
around because he was the only mechanic
where there really no other adult needed
alive for anything else how about
someone who knows the password for the
adult sites uh we had our st. got no gas
no I don't need ya got no diesel fuel
neither your telephone I need to use
your file but I ain't got no telephone
we ain't got no kids we ain't got no
corn either in fact I'm not even here we
talking to I'm just a scarecrow you get
on that right fork then you've been
hemming for to know time but they make a
Korean barbecue out of his dog and
decide to kill him off because after
three years of fixing stuff never
escaping and telling nobody about the
mass slaughter that happened in that
neighborhood it's finally time to kill
him because he told two people not to go
in their neighborhood they made better
choices following the Church of the
magic 8-ball
I find that sign shaped the tiniest bit
like a cross revolting as they continue
to get more lost we see the kids
honoring their corn on the cross and
listening to sermons by their leader
Isaac Isaac is the best fucking thing in
this movie the Lord did come to me and
he was a shape it was he who walks
behind the rows Isaac is the movie Jesus
camp in Reverse he's the Munchkin
version of the bad guy from Manos he's
every self-indulgent prophet that fits
into most overhead compartments Joseph
has taken his things and fled this happy
place so take you his life
and fill his blood and he's also a
wanted criminal
oh not for mass murder not for brain
watching all these kids but because he
steals every single scene in this movie
but let not the flesh salute the call
cast him instead upon the road I know
now why receptors in a cornfield and so
the rest of the actors can have some
scenery to chew on question not my
judgment Malachi
I am the giver of his word and the
interesting thing this actor was 25
years old when he did this role yep he
has one of those conditions where he
looks and sounds a million times younger
than he really is and yet even knowing
that he still comes across as it's not
knows little pissant commanding his
legion of good sons and Bad Seeds he's
just a treasure yuck that the blue man
was offered up on to him so shall be the
unbelievers no Isaac I believe you but I
would never tell your whiny wisdom Oh
pointing at them but that's how
intimidating he is the one thing I never
quite got though is how did Isaac
convince all these kids to kill the
adults I mean he has the authority now
but how did he get it from them before
we're kids just watching TV and like
yeah copy the cowboy we'll be right back
after our message from our favorite
sponsor Isaac the blood of the old Chou
spill rise my children kill now kill now
um don't listen to him this week kids
ugh he's a very naughty boy
no we should have been paid in maize
Peter and Vikki show up into town as we
partake in a thrilling amount of looking
looking that even more looking yeah it
became to see why this was originally a
short story they come across on kids but
they disappear pretty fast so we go back
to more looking the film becomes so
bored with a walking doll that this
actually counts as a scare honey please
turn your children off they do however
come across Sarah are you mommy and
daddy around here in the cornfield what
are they doing there fertilizing mostly
they try to get more answers out there
but she just seems too shy to respond so
Peter decides to leave his wife and the
little girl behind because seriously
what's the worst that could happen in
this child throat-slitting town things
just aren't happening fast I'm sure we
can move past all this tedious looking
with even more looking I'm gonna go look
at the Town Hall
yep this looks like Town Hall he sees
corn is placed everywhere because
remember corn scary now boom and notices
some strange rendition of their
religious pictures must be part of their
Jesus goes to Willy Wonka's factory set
look Vicky gets in trouble when she
become surrounded by Isaac
second-in-command Malachi
who are you have you heard the good news
about the corn seize her
we then see this movies brilliant idea
for shadowing yes he looks at a picture
of a dragon burning a woman while Vikki
is being attacked dude doesn't really
had anything I think it's pretty obvious
she's endangered by the sharp objects
being thrown at her not an Eragon
coloring book it's like me confirming
something I already know
so it did hurt corny
oh wow oh you really need James Cameron
to write for me let me take her away as
we see the kids drawing predicta what
was gonna happen like she predicted
everything else that was gonna happen
why this looks like a job for Stephen
King's favorite trope an exploring
psychic charm
so you're psychic huh where did that
come from I don't know how did you do it
I don't know what you do with in the
future I don't know I took it out of the
story when we miss it that much probably
not off you go unexplained psychic child
the less we know about you the lazier
the turn Peters vehicle into a corner of
a car not allowing him to follow Vicki
to Isaac the fact you want to kill me is
fine but doing it by placing me on a
cross shaped crosses just revolting but
there are burnt kernels among the corn
you know the laws he's the god of blood
sacrifice not ceremonies found on your
knees heretic no you don't strike one
apart from us I will not indulge your
quarter life crisis seize him punish him
cut him down I command you
I am the word and the giver of his laws
I am the snapper right bitches do it now
or your punishment she'll be a thousand
times a thousand gets its more horrible
than the last they are tired of your
talk Isaac I refuse to believe that
nobody can ever get tired of Isaac that
he was tied with Isaac is tied with life
yo daddy idols Black team you will
punish you the John availble devour you
I love you just make an Isaac doll No
you'll have to I remain a prototype I am
the word and the giver of his laws take
you his life I spill his blood look for
it in your produce section
you
attention your parents are lying you
need a balanced breakfast how about some
nice Brussels
newsflash welcome to the 90s dad with
kids rule and we eat what we want like
sugar frosted children of the corn
flakes full of extreme radicalness to
the max that's most unorthodox yes
because parents just don't understand
that's why you must rise up against them
and spill their blood for a hop it has
the awesome taste that no grown-up can
see so take you his life follow these
anti motor back to your salvation well
munching on that sweet frosted taste
there's even games on the back like
finding your way through the corn maze
hey huh I can't find my way out because
there is no way out that was gonna
behind the row shop hash whoa dude
let not the flesh pollute the corn
indeed maniac sack catch them instead
upon your bowl or high fructose corn
syrup awaits them to the extreme do it
now your punishment shall be a thousand
times a thousand texts each one moment
hunger frosted children of the corn
flakes is part of this complete
breakfast
I am the word and the giver of his laws
read
so while Peter looks from Vicki he comes
across what I think is Tom Cruise's
initiation into Scientology stop stop
holy Outlander
oh well that stopped us your presence
does profane this holy place he will
reckon with you God I think we stumbled
across the Church of Kim Davis so what
do you mean as it is written what in
this if you rewriting the whole thing or
just the parts that suit your needs yep
definitely the Church of Kim Davis but
malachi comes to chase him with his army
of Goonies Wow thank you really want to
make the most of this one scene I will
throw everything into this garble of
vowels the corners gonna rub all tonight
Outlander yeah why is why pushing the
only thing that can defeat them if the
abracadaniel way of defending yourself
shit
Malachi smells his mark hamill hair but
luckily job is there to sneak him out
and lead them to where Vicki is being
held that and things are not looking so
good for Isaac either why does the
sacrifice include turning yourself into
Eric Cartman
so why is it get consumed by um liquid
Schwartz which apparently jiffy pops him
into hell
but Peter arrives in time to save Vikki
with probably the fakest fistfight
you'll see in a while
Hey look out you must hit on my neck one
on any less real and WWE will be
knocking at your door any religion
without love passion is false Peter
gives a big speech about how the demonic
religion is bogus only to discover that
actually it was pretty much all true
that Brotherhood at the Rhoyne they'll
just watch yeah he wants you to oh man
that was way off
well he'll see and everybody gotta go so
as the demon devil non explaining thing
goes after everybody our heroes get the
idea to burn down the field after
someone tried to do it before inspired
by a Bible passage
surprisingly corn is still not scary
guys so it's more like torture porn for
ol McDonald's job saves him but Peter is
surprisingly kind of a dick about it
what are you doing here see if I save
you next time a vegetable goes Evil Dead
on your ass so he stops the evil entity
from taking that left turn at
Albuquerque and lights up the field
destroying the monster hmm now let's see
Stephen King's disappointed climaxes
have included a giant spider alien death
Ray's self-aware trucks and chopping
Bigfoot testicles how can we possibly
get lamer than that with Casper the
Friendly explosion I am not even kidding
that is what you were supposed to be
afraid of the entire time that is a
whole new level of not giving a fuck I
guess it's supposed to be open to
interpretation about what it exactly is
but the only thing I'm interpreting is
what it looks like more Jabba the Hutt's
exploding fetus a pumpkin ice cream
achieving orgasm or the Annoying Orange
if he was crying cauliflower flesh the
sign guys this is a scene that really
fucking needs it Wow
so after our anti-religious heroes find
out only demons are real but the Bible
save the day they walk back with the
reassured confidence that evil spiritual
identities can just be blown up with a
few tanks of gas oh look at those cute
giggling kids it's almost like they
didn't witness any of the extreme
horrors that would freak any low child
out we didn't even cry when our parents
were slaughtered we're kind of its
soulless as the corn you're walking
through this movie however has one last
gear up their sleeves
Oh obviously they didn't bring it out
because that was a ridiculous lame-ass
joke it's actually so lame that the
movie just kind of gives up on it yeah
that's really how it ends no music no
scary buildup it's like even they knew
how stupid this was it just wanted out
as quickly as possible
yeah fuck it we're done folks
we didn't want to put that ending in but
the studio made us boo I guess and that
was the awkwardly ending awkwardly
beginning awkwardly Stephen King the
money doesn't really bring much new to
the scary kid idea and what it does
bring is either to slow moving or
doesn't make any sense
the only scares it focuses on is that of
violence which is a shame because you
can really do a lot with scary kids and
movies as other films have shown above
is willy and psychologically but nope
these kids just stab stuff in quote
scripture that's it if you don't find
that especially creepy then you're not
gonna find this especially creepy but to
be fair the best thing about the film is
just how fucking hard the kids are
trying these actors are throwing their
fucking all into this movie even in the
tiniest scenes sure a lot of its
over-the-top but they're just so much
fun to watch and their dedication to
this insanity is pretty much what makes
the movie especially Isaac who in my
opinion can do no wrong
in fact I think we should rise up
against the flesh of the old and give
our undying allegiance to Isaac wait a
minute who wrote that Isaac got to him
and Isaac how did you get anyone to
follow you you don't understand I have
incredible persuasive powers I can even
intimidate you with the power of the
card
yes quite I mean educating it's still
not scary
not even the bad ones new what am I
going to do my whole team is fearful
brute violence and now psychological
effort how's that gonna get me
popularity today it's Isaac's extreme
haunted house see what everyone is
calling the scariest attraction this
year can you go
Oh
no playing to your interferes here we
just beat the living shit out of you
most extreme houses let you walk out
with cuts and bruises here we literally
beat you to death just listen to the
final words of these satisfied customers
you know I thought real scares for
psychological with brilliant illusions
and creative imagery but now I can see
it can just be a guy in a costume
beating us up we got lines around the
block I guess people are more forgiving
the lazy scares with violence just beat
the shit out of somebody and that's
about it for nostalgia we know I only
have a top 11 list to do and after that
will be November so thank you so much
for watching you don't like the fact
there's only two Halloween reviews this
year
you want me to pull the Simpsons
Halloween special and go one week into
November with another Halloween review
okay I'm only doing it to keep you happy
until then I'm the Nostalgia Critic and
rule loves to pick an asshole
you
ah
Outlander
hey beer list of Walker doing the
charity shout out and this week we are
doing the Wounded Warrior Project and
this is something that's exactly what
sounds like it is trying to get money
attention and care to people that have
served for us in the past and have had
usually terrible things happen to them
whether it be physical or psychological
or financial these are people that
deserve our absolute best and are not
always getting it so this is an
organization that tries to come together
in every possible way to help these
people out every single way imaginable
they try to benefit these people these
are soldiers that signed up and put
their lives on the line and they have
had so much stuff happen to them and
this is an organization that's trying to
say thank you thank you for your hard
service you deserve the absolute best
that we have to offer and they are
trying to make that happen through
fundraisers and triathlons and all sorts
of various events they try anything they
can to try to get attention money and
care to the people that deserve it most
this is definitely a good organization
to check out if you go to their YouTube
page you can see all the good stuff that
they do please definitely take the time
to go and support the people who have
put everything on the line to keep us
safe